[Applause]
at the 2021 billboard music awards on
sunday
it was smooth all around during their
performance of butter
[Music]
coming live from korea bts brought us
their latest chart-topping song
not only that the k-pop super group
nabbed four awards
following the success of last year's hit
song dynamite
we wanted to share some fresh energy
with everyone through dynamite
we think and we think this award is
proof that we achieve that goal
on thursday bts broke yet another record
with the debut of butters music video
racking up 21 million views on youtube
in the first
hour
[Music]
bts chatted with e.t last week about the
magic behind their latest hit
yeah i'm so excited to see you guys oh i
see the butter everywhere
oh tell me why this song is called
butter what can we expect
yes sir and you can see the color of
butter on on his hair
perfect you're matching the vibe um you
know we
say smooth like butter will it will this
song have people moving smooth like
butter
of course smooth
ooh boys before they're good
you are of course killing it how does it
feel for you
emotionally to break record after record
with your music
yeah he was so good i'm sure you are
excited to perform and the fans so
miss seeing you what do you hope for for
when you can tour again
foreign
[Music]
foreign